m
[Musique]
réjean vanasse à 83 ans il habite avec
sa femme dans une résidence pour aînés
[Musique]
avant lakovic 19 il conseillait les
jeunes pour 25 sous au collège de
maisonneuve
ça vous apporte à vous de parler avec
ces jeunes là je te retrouves à vue ça
colle au chai futile génial y est prêt
pour une personne âgée d'être inutile
rien de pire que le printemps amer de la
pandémie prisonnier dans sa tour de la
rue sherbrooke
françois legault a forcé le confinement
des personnes âgées
après des explosions massives dans les
ch et celle des et les résidences en
jamboree l'eau ce sont plus de 7
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait mal au total
c'est l infantilisation au total
à 96 en plus il n'a double brunet aime
recevoir polie c'est la chanteuse
pauline julien à l'époque la femme
engagée fêtait avec des artistes dans
cette vidéo elle fête son anniversaire
entourée de sa famille et femmes de ma
génération ne pas hériter d'une femme
érudite
piqué au vif par le sort qu'on a réservé
aux personnes âgées durant la pandémie
ça a été une révolte intérieure ça
s'peut peau qu'on accepte de bâtir un
québec comme show ces la plume rempli de
rage qu'elle a composé une lettre tous
vendus sous le signe du lendemain qui
renvoie la personne âgée une image
décline des crips de l'aude vite je veux
dans mon texte orientée vers le
développement économique des choses mais
nous on compte pas là dedans parce qu'en
mai nous y'a du y ait davantage valable
au niveau d'une envie zink du visible ce
qui était surtout visible pendant la
pandémie
c'est le nombre de décès plus de 5400
personnes sont mortes de lakovic 19 au
québec
neuf personnes sur dix avait 70 ans et
plus dont la majorité habitait en ch et
celle des ou en résidence
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que le
québec a abandonné fait vieux c'est pas
ben donne hélas pas longtemps qu'on les
a abandonnés c'est juste que l'oeil
saumon c'est de voir que pendant des
années ça fait 45 ans qu'on le sait
qu'il ya eu une espèce d'omerta de
silence autour de ce qu'ils vivaient
dans ces maisons là une responsabilité
collective dans l'angle mort des
politiciens depuis des décennies c'est
des gens qui consultent un peu qui font
peu partie des décisions majeures qui
concerne québec on parle beaucoup les
crs ld maintient les vieux là il y en a
beaucoup plus que question sérieuse ldc
déjà contribuer à la société
lucile nadeau brunet rêve d'un grand
rendez-vous où toutes les personnes
âgées seraient invités c'est une
politique du vieillissement qui regroupe
et à la grandeur de la province
non aux aînés pour leur demander ce
qu'ils veulent comme milieu de vie où
ils veulent chez penguin dans les
premières dernières années qu'il est en
rêve
monsieur valence oui pour 25 sous huy
un conseil au premier ministre c'est
consulter les vieux d'amendé l'âge
qu'ils ont besoin
et peut-être que j'avais plus de chance
a raconté le japon
il s'y marie josée paquet comme radio
canada montréal
[Musique]